KABUL.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT,
KABUL AIR BASE PLUNGED INTO
DARKNESS.
NOTHING HAPPENED LIKE THAT
BEFORE.
IT'S AN ENORMOUS PIECE OF
PROPERTY.
THEY HAVE A HOSPITAL, SHOPS,
GYMS, HANGERS AND BARRACKS.
LAST MONTH BAGRAM HAD A PRISON
THAT HELD THOUSANDS OF FOREIGN
FIGHTERS INCLUDING ISIS AND THE
TALIBAN.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 20 YEARS,
THE LIGHTING WENT OUT AT BAGRAM.
LOCALS UNDERSTOOD WHAT WAS GOING
ON.
WITHOUT WARNING, THE U.S.
MILITARY JUST LEFT.
SPLIT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT
AND TURNED OFF THE POWER AS THEY
DID.
THE NEW AFGHAN COMMANDER FLED,
TOO.
IN MINUTES, LOOTERS DESCENDED.
THEY FOUND THOUSANDS OF
VEHICLES, A HUGE CACHE OF
WEAPONS AND AMMUNITION.
THE PENTAGON DIDN'T SEEM
CONCERNED.
MARK MILLEY, THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
JOINT CHIEFS OF STAFF EXPLAINED
THAT "BAGRAM IS NOT NECESSARY
TACTICALLY FOR WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO DO IN AFGHANISTAN."
THAT TURNS OUT TO BE A MASSIVE
MISCALCULATION.
THAT IS CLEAR.
THE DECISION TO ABANDON THE AIR
FIELD IS IDIOTIC AND LED TO THE
KILLING OF 13 SERVICE MEMBERS
YESTERDAY.
GIVEN THE LOCAL, KABUL'S AIRPORT
IS IMPOSSIBLE TO DEFEND.
YET DESPITE THE FACT THAT IT
CAN'T BE DEFENDED, IT'S THE ONLY
WAY FOR AMERICAN CITIZENS TO GET
OUT OF THE COUNTRY.
AS BILL SAID IT, ABANDONING
BAGRAM AIR BASE SAYING YES,
CAN'T DO AND NOT THIS IS MADNESS
BECAUSE I'M PUTTING THE LIVES OF
AMERICANS AT RISK AND YOU NEED
TO FIND SOMEONE ELSE TO DO IT.
TRAGICALLY NOBODY IN AUTHORITY
WAS BRAVE ENOUGH TO SAY THAT.
INSTEAD EVERY TURN, THERE WERE
UNWISE DECISIONS THAT MADE THEIR
COUNTRY LOOK WEAKER.
WHAT IS INTERESTING, THE VERY
SAME PEOPLE ARE NOW OVERSEEING
WHAT MAY BE THE LARGEST AIRLIFT
IN GENERATIONS.
AN AIRLATION OF
THOUSANDS:CITIZENS INTO THE WEST
AND OUR COUNTRY.
SO HOW IS THAT AIRLIFT GOING?
YOU'RE HEARING A LOT ABOUT IT
BUT VERY FEW DETAILS.
WHO, FOR EXAMPLE, ARE ALL OF
THESE AFGHANS?
MANY ON THEIR WAY HERE.
THE TRUTH IS DESPITE WHAT
THEY'RE TELLING YOU, WHY HAVE NO
IDEA WHO THEY ARE.
WE DON'T KNOW.
WE LEARNED FOR EXAMPLE 100 THE
REFUGEES, PEOPLE THAT WE'RE TOLD
BY HEROS BY DEFINITION ARE IN
FACT ON TERROR WATCH LISTS.
ONE MAN WE EVACUATED,2 FOR ISIS.
TODAY AN AFGHAN INTERPRETER SAYS
THIS THING IS HAPPENING ALL THE
TIME.
PEOPLE ARE GETTING ON PLANES IN
KABUL WITHOUT ANY PROOF OF
IDENTIFICATION.
IT'S LIKE VOTING IN CALIFORNIA.
LISTEN.
>> I KNOW PEOPLE THAT HAVE THE
SAME SITUATION THAT I AM IN.
THEY'RE GROWING TO THE UNITED
STATES.
BUT THERE'S PEOPLE INSIDE THE
AIRPORT THAT NEVER WORKED.
THEY KNOW SOMEBODY WITH A
PASSPORT.
THAT'S HOW THEY GOT INSIDE.
THEY KNOW SOMEBODY BUT THEY
NEVER WORKED.
>> THAT'S NOT AN ANALYST ON
MSNBC.
THAT'S SOMEONE AT THE KABUL
AIRPORT.
IF YOU LISTEN CAREFULLY, YOU'LL
HEAR A LOT OF STORIES LIKE THAT
ONE.
ONE PILOT FROM UNITED AIRLINES
THAT IS FLYING PEOPLE OUT AS THE
CIVILIAN AIR LEFT FLEET, HE SAID
HE WAS NEVER GIVEN A PASSENGER
MANIFEST.
WHEN HIS AIRPLANE ARRIVED AT
DULLES, THE STATE DEPARTMENT
REFUSED TO SHARE ANY PASSENGER
INFORMATION WITH CUSTOMS AND
BORDER PATROL.
THEY JUST WHISK ON THROUGH.
THAT MEANS AS ALWAYS UNNAMED
FOREIGN NATIONALS GOT FAR BETTER
TREATMENT THAN YOU WOULD GET IF
YOU LANDED IN DULLES AIRPORT.
SURPRISED?
THERE'S A LOT OF, THIS ANOTHER
COMMERCIAL AIRLINE EMPLOYEE A
FLIGHT ATTENDANT, WAS TOLD HER
FLIGHT CREW WOULD BE FERRYING
AMERICAN CIVILIANS THAT WERE
FROM KABUL.
SHE WAS HAPPY TO DO THAT.
WHEN THEY ARRIVED IN KABUL, THEY
LEARNED THEY WOULD HAVE NO
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
INSTEAD AFGHAN THEY TRANSPORTED
AFGHAN NATIONALS.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO WEAR MASKS.
RULES ARE ONLY LIKE THAT FOR YOU
AND THE REST OF US THAT PAY FOR
IT.
THEY DON'T APPLY FOR PEOPLE
WITHOUT PASSPORTS FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
THAT MAY SHOCK YOU BUT IT'S
NORMAL IN WASHINGTON.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS ACTIVELY
DEMANDING IT.
EVERY REFUGEE IS A POTENTIAL NEW
VOTER.
SANDY CORTEZ WAS WORRIED ABOUT
THE UNVETTED TRUMP VOTERS
WANDERING WHAT THEY THOUGHT WAS
THEIR CAPITOL.
SANDY CORTEZ THOUGHT SHE WOULD
BE RAPED DESPITE THE FACT SHE
WASN'T THERE.
BUT STRANGELY, CORTEZ SO
SENSITIVE ANT HER OWN SAFETY IS
NOT CONCERNED ABOUT SENDING HUGE
AND UNKNOWN NUMBERS OF REFUGEES
IN YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD.
SHE'S SAYING WE HAVE SEEN WHAT
AFGHAN MIGRATION HAS DONE TO
EUROPE AND SHE APPROVES IT.
SHE WANTS MORE.
>> IN ORDER TO CARRY OUT AND IN
ORDER TO MAKE GOOD ON THE ROLE
THAT WE HAVE PLAYED IN THIS
VIOLENCE, WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE A HOME
FOR THE PEOPLE WHOSE LIVED HAVE
BEEN UP ENDED BY
INTERVENTIONISTS U.S. FOREIGN
POLICY.
AS A RESULT, I'M PROUD TO HAVE A
CO WRITTEN A LETTER WITH BARBARA
LEE TO URGE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO AT LEAST SET
THEIR REFUGEE QUOTAS TO MAKE IT
NO LESS THAN 200,000.
>> SO THE MACROQUESTION IS WHAT
DO SILLY CHILDREN LIKE THAT HAVE
ANY POWER WHATSOEVER IN THIS
COUNTRY?
WHY SHOULD SOME GIRL FROM B.U.
THAT KNOWS NOTHING HAS NEVER DEN
ANYTHING IN HER LIFE BE IN
CHARGE OF THE WAY YOUR COUNTRY
LOOKS GOING FORWARD FOR THE NEXT
100 YEARS?
WHO KNOWS.
THAT'S DEMOCRACY AS WE PRACTICE
IT.
LISTEN CAREFULLY WHAT SHE'S
SAYING.
NO FEWER THAN 200 REFUGEES, WHY?
BECAUSE WE'RE EVIL AND WE
DESERVE IT.
WE SHOULDN'T HAVEN'T SPENT 20
YEARS IN AFGHANISTAN.
BY WHY DID WE GO THERE?
BECAUSE AL-QUAIDA WAS USING TO
IT BLOW UP THE WORLD TRADE
CENTERS AND ATTACK THE PENTAGON.
THERE WAS A REASON WE WENT THERE
EVEN THOUGH ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ TURNED OUT TO BE A
TOTAL DISASTER.
WE DON'T OWE THE COUNTRY
ANYTHING.
THEY WERE THE STAGING GROUND FOR
9-11.
SHE WAS A CHILD.
DOESN'T REMEMBER THAT.
HER VIEW NOW HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THIS CITY OF
WASHINGTON.
IT'S NOT JUST DEMOCRATS WE'RE
SAD TO REPORT.
HERE'S ADAM KINZINGER.
SHE'S FOR FOREIGN NATIONALS ON
THE NO FLY LIST.
>> THEY'RE PAINTING AFGHAN
REFUGEES AS INVADERS.
THERE'S UNDERTONES OF RACISM
HERE.
>> WHAT YOU SEE IN THE MEDIA ECO
CHAMBER, THIS FEAR MONGERING,
THEY'RE COMING TO YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD THESE HORDES OF
PEOPLE THAT HAVEN'T BEEN VETTED
THAT IS NOT AMERICAN.
REFUGEES TO THIS COUNTRY HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN ENTREPRENEURIAL.
WHY KNOW THAT, THEY COME HERE,
WORK HARD, FIGHT HARD FOR
SUCCESS.
SO IF ANYBODY WANTS TO FEAR
MONGER AND DON'T THAT DARKNESS
IN YOUR HEART SO YOU CAN WIN AN
ELECTION, A, YOU'RE EVIL AT YOUR
HEART OR B, A CHARLOTTEAN.
>> Tucker: WAIT A SECOND, SON.
WE CAN DEBATE THE REFUGEES.
BUT MAKING THIS A RACISM ISSUE?
THEY'RE WHITER THAN YOU ARE.
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH RACE.
SO KNOCK IT OFF.
LISTEN TO WHAT HE'S SAYING.
FOREIGNERS ARE MORE IMPRESSIVE
THAN YOU ARE.
THEY'RE MORE ENTREPRENEURIAL.
IF YOU DON'T AGREE WITH THAT,
SAID ADAM KINSINGER, IF YOU
THOUGHT THE POINT OF AMERICA TO
SERVE THE PEOPLE THAT LIVE HERE,
AND WE'RE QUOTING, YOU'RE EVIL.
THAT'S HIS POSITION.
YOU'RE EVIL.
SO NOW YOU KNOW WHY HE'S NOT
BOTHERED BY THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
HE'S NOT BOTHERED BECAUSE HE
AGREES WITH THE RESULT.
FEWER NATIVE BORN WHINERS, MORE
GRATEFUL FOREIGNERS TO WHOM --
WHO FEEL INDEBTED TO US, PEOPLE
WE CAN CLAIM TO HAVE RESCUED.
ADAM KINSINGER IS A PATHETIC
PERSON.
HE CRYING WHEN HE THINKS ABOUT A
GOOD PERSON HE IS.
WE DON'T WANT TO SINGLE HIM OUT.
THE POINT IS THAT HIS ATTITUDES
ARE VERY COMMON IN WASHINGTON
AND THE NUMBERS PROVE IT.
SINCE JULY, THE UNITED STATES
HAS EVACUATED MORE THAN 100,000
PEOPLE FROM AFGHANISTAN.
ALL HEROS?
ALL AMERICANS?
NO.
AS OF TONIGHT, ABOUT 5,000 TOTAL
ARE AMERICAN CITIZENS.
5%.
SO YOU'RE THINKING THE OTHER NIP
5% MUST BE HEROS?
ALL TRANSLATORS?
95,000 TRANSLATORS?
NO.
JUST TODAY THE STATE DEPARTMENT
ADMITTED IT HAS NO IDEA HOW MANY
PEOPLE HAVE WHAT WE CALL SPECIAL
IMMIGRANT VISAS.
THAT WOULD INDICATE THAT THEY
WORKED FOR THE U.S. MILITARY AND
MIGHT BE HEROS.
MAYBE TRANSLATORS.
THEY'RE NOT HEROS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHO THEY ARE.
>> THE CONTEXT OF THIS MASSIVE
AND UNPRECEDENTED EVACUATION
EFFORT OUR GOAL GOAL IS TO HAVE
BRING AS MANY PEOPLE TO SAFETY
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
SO IN MANY CASES WE ARE GOING TO
BE IN A BETTER POSITION TO
PROVIDE YOU FIDELITY ON NUMBERS
IN THE COMING DAYS AND THE
COMING WEEKS.
AS THIS PROCESS HAS BEEN ON
GOING, WE'RE PUTTING AS MANY
PEOPLE ON AS MANY PLANES AS WE
CAN.
>> Tucker: SO TO RESTATE,
THEY'RE NOT ALL HEROS.
WE CAN'T SAY THAT BECAUSE WE
DON'T KNOW WHO THEY ARE.
THE HEAD OF U.S. NORTHERN
COMMAND, GENERAL GLENN VAN HIRK
JUST ADMITTED THIS.
HE TOLD OUR JENNIFER GRIFFIN
THAT MORE THAN HALF OF THE
AFGHAN REFUGEES COMING INTO THE
UNITED STATES DO NOT HAVE
SPECIAL IMMIGRANT VISAS.
SO THEY DIDN'T WORK FOR THE U.S.
MILITARY.
THEY'RE NOT HEROS, THEY'RE NOT
TRANSLATORS.
WHY DO WE HAVE A MORAL
OBLIGATION TO LET THEM LIVE HERE
AND GIVE THEM FREE HEALTHCARE?
WE HAVE NO PROOF THEY'RE LOYAL.
WE HAVE NO PROOF THEY'RE
ENTREPRENEURIAL.
WHY ARE WE TAKING THEM IN?
THE MILITARY WON'T SAY.
INSTEAD THE PENTAGON IS DOING IT
AND BUILDING HOUSING FOR THEM.
>> TODAY THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE CAN ANNOUNCE THEY'VE
AUTHORIZED QUANTICO, VIRGINIA,
FORT PICKET, VIRGINIA AND
HOLLOMAN AIR FORCE BASE TO
PROVIDE FAMILIES AND OTHER
AT-RISK INDIVIDUALS HOUSING.
THESE INSTALLATIONS JOINT FORT
LEE, FORT McCOY, FORT BLISS AND
JOINT BASE DIX IN PROVIDING THIS
SUPPORT.
THE DEFENSE DEPARTMENT WILL
SUPPORT THE STATE DEPARTMENT IN
PROVIDING TEMPORARY HOUSING AND
SUPPORT IN THE UNITED STATES FOR
A CAPACITY OF UP TO 50,000
AFGHAN SPECIAL IMMIGRANT VISA
APPLICANTS, THEIR FAMILIES AND
OTHER AT-RISK INDIVIDUALS.
>> Tucker: MAN, THEY ALWAYS TAKE
TRAGEDY AND RUN WITH IT TO
CHANGE THIS COUNTRY OUTSIDE THE
BOUNDS OF DEMOCRACY.
THEY DON'T ASK ANYONE TO VOTE ON
IT.
THEY DON'T ASK FOR PERMISSION.
THEY JUST TAKE YOUR SADNESS AND
BEWILDERMENT AND LEVERAGE IT TO
CHANGE EVERYTHING.
THEY DID THAT WITH GEORGE
FLOYD'S DEATH.
>> THEY DID IT WITH COVID, WHICH
THEY HELPED CREATE THROUGH GAIN
OF FUNCTION RESEARCH AND DOING
IT NOW IN THE WAKE OF THE
TRAGEDY IN AFGHANISTAN THAT THEY
CAUSED.
SO WE JUST LEARNED THAT 50,000
SIV APPLICANTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND OTHER AT-RISK
INDIVIDUALS SO WHAT IS AN
AT-RISK INDIVIDUAL?
WE HAVE NO IDEA BUT A TERM OUR
MILITARY IS USING A LOT.
THE HEAD OF CENTRAL COMMAND USED
THAT TERM, "AT-RISK AFGHANS."
RIGHT NOW ANYBODY IN AFGHANISTAN
IS AT RISK.
THAT'S THE BIDEN'S
ADMINISTRATION THOUGHT AS WELL.
SOME OF THESE AT-RISK
INDIVIDUALS ARE BEING HOUSED IN
SHELTERS.
IN FORT BLISS, THEY'RE MAKING
TEMPORARY HOUSING FOR ALLIES
REFUGE.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT YES CAN
GET BEHIND.
THEN YOU REALIZE WHO THEY MIGHT
BE.
THE PENTAGON CONSIDERS THE
TALIBAN AN ALLY.
WE'RE GIVING THE